as Enterprise Architect I takes care not
only of the technology aspects but also
of the organizational aspect my
principal challenge in my role is to
becaming a change agent we are living in
a very fast changing world so we have to
adapt to technology change cloud in this
moment play the role of Innovation Lab
and is an accelerator for deploying
simple projects supporting our business
we could consider a shift to an hybrid
cloud as an opportunity to develop
laboratory projects to test new
technologies to test new services and
then bring them in a more structured way
inside our IT environment to provide
final services to the customers so it's
an opportunity that we are trying to
exploit and we are starting doing it
with the IBM bluemix the way in which an
old legacy application that is core
banking application reacts is a very
slow pace and changing on the other hand
business requirements of fast changing
so I need to provide solution to the
finite user that are very quick to
deploy from the operational point of
view we have a priority in setting up an
Enterprise Service bus to decouple our
front-end from the legacy de Kamp's this
is necessary just to speed up our
reaction in answering the business
requirements with this kind of
Enterprise Service bus we would able to
attach to our IT infrastructure external
service already already ready for mass
consumption it enable ITB modality our
idea is using cloud to enable the
integration between the external service
world and our internal service
middle-earth synergy has been an in able
to demonstrate to our business that the
bimodal fatigue is a reality as possible
so we can invest money and time to
exploit new solutions to be faster and
more efficient